there are a few different ways to copy
or clone an array let's look at some
here we start with this original array
true true undefined false nor these are
all items in the array so the common way
to copy raises with the slice method now
the slice method is usually used to
break apart an array into two different
parts but we can also use it to copy an
entire array just that we'll copy the
entire array and you can also use the
spread operator to copy an array and
that just copied the array again these
three dots are the spread operator and
that just spreads out this original
array into wherever we're putting it so
spread out the original array into the
new array let's do a test here to see if
that worked and you can see there's a
lock it's gonna log that copy one and
it's gonna log copy two and both of them
are the same as the original copy now
this does not always work if you have an
array or an object within your array
whenever you have an array or an object
in your array you need to do deep
copying let me show you an example now
in this array there's an array within
the array so you can see there's the two
sets of brackets each array only has one
item so in one array there's the item
free code camp in the other array is the
array that has the item free code camp
so if we just try the normal method of
copying if we just use slice here
now we're going to actually try to
modify that shallow copy it we went to
the array at index 0 which is the first
array so I'm trying to put something on
to that first array within the array I'm
trying to push is great
so let's console that logged in and see
what happens huh
well look at this I love the deep array
and I logged the shallow copy array and
so the deeper rains freako can't a
shallow copy should actually be a
completely other array because we've
copied it into a shallow copy and then
we're just going to push is great to the
shallow copy just so you know we are
just logging the index 0 so we're not
trying to unlock the whole array we're
just trying to log the array within the
array that's why we put into 0 here but
after adding is great it's actually if
you see this up here its inning is great
to the deep array and the shallow copy
you can see that it's lot both of them
are the same now the reason for that is
because anytime you have an array within
an array in JavaScript or if you have an
object within an array in JavaScript in
the original array is just a pointer to
an array or a pointer to an object
inside that original array so when we
are doing a copy of the array we're just
copying the pointers to this original
array so when we push is great we're not
pushing is great to the shallow copy
directly we're pushing is great to the
pointer to the other array and since
both of them are pointing to the same
second array it's going to add the is
great to to basically both copies the
deep array and the shallow copy if you
have an array that has other arrays or
other objects within the array you
really need to
a deep copy if you want to make sure
everything is copied as you would expect
so let me show you how to do that
some people have fancy for loops and and
a lot of code to do it but there is
actually a trick it's a secret way that
makes it a lot easier let me show you
that so this is it so basically we're
gonna pass in this deep array to the
json stringify method and this is going
to create a string of the whole array
including a raise within the array and
objects within the array and then when I
call that json dot parse method which is
going to convert this string back into a
javascript object or a javascript array
and then we're gonna assign the whole
thing to that deep copy variable let's
try what we did before I'm just gonna
copy this code up here we're gonna take
change shadow copy to deep copy I'm
gonna push is great we're gonna console
that log deep array and deep copy and
just to make this more clear I'm going
to take this out and take this out and
now let's run that okay now it behaves
how you would expected to behave in a
copy so we're gonna console dot log the
array within the deep array and then the
array within the deep copy and the first
one's gonna be free code camp and then
because we push the is great the second
one is going to be free code camp is
great well that was a few ways to copy
arrays thanks for watching my name is Bo
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good